program now at UNLV is arming students
with skills to keep them safe should
they be in a potential dangerous
situation Brian will Dives
are turning the tables on violence
against them
girls on guard is a program here at the
University Police Services that is
empowering women through the tenets of
jujitsu sure so you see like he has
nowhere to go but to go back so you're
going to do the same thing follow his
arms break it down here We Do It All We
flip We Roll we
it's been it's all Hands-On every nine
seconds in the U.S a woman is assaulted
or beaten this free class is giving
women the power to fight back it's so
different than just watching a YouTube
video or reading a book about it you're
working with instructors right here
physically in person the self-defense
tactics include using the principles of
Leverage angles pressure and timing
yes okay yeah much easier yeah it's a
way for these students to understand
body mechanics and self-defense in a
controlled environment hoping never to
need it to feel prepared for any
eventual circumstances we never know and
I want to feel that I can protect myself
University Police Services says they
plan to continue this program in the
future reporting in Las Vegas Brian will
8 News Now
we can all you to also tell you this is
the first class of its kind since before
the pandemic and they really do want to
grow the program and they encourage
students and staff in the public to take
a class so we posted information for you
on our website at 8newsnow.com